bonjour et bienvenue dans le studio
diagonale tv aujourd'hui avec un joueur
d'exception en france puisque non
seulement une grand maître international
mais c'est aussi le sélectionneur de
l'équipe de france et miss hélas pierre
vaselli bonjour sébastien je leur ai
alors super tournoi pour toi cette année
puisque tu rencontré tout ce que tu peux
prendre dans l'équipe
eh oui babin pathos mais pas ma forte
opposition
ouais et donc dernière partie très
compliqué contre christian qui mon
coéquipier à bois colombes
oui beaucoup équipier est possible aux
sélectionnés au signal audio
sélectionnés qui jouait le titre
alors pour moi je joue à pas grand-chose
sur senna n'a pas dit oui alors donc tu
fais quand même bon tournoi puisque tu
fais 50 % des points oui je suis un peu
déçu ce que j'ai laissé passer beaucoup
d'occasions contre tigran avec les noirs
c'était c'était nul très facilement la
fin contre etienne c'était pas très
compliqué non plus je suis un peu déçu
de l'ensemble ans que j'ai eu pas mal
d'opportunités
ouais mais bon tu es un très plaisant il
faut améliorer les passages à vide du
colisée qui pourrait faire les quatre
heures de jeu souvent je fais des
petites 0,20 par action physique
peut-être important je fais beaucoup de
sport mais là c'est sympa mais ça c'est
pas facile avec le temps weitz avec
notes vont ils mettre la pression c'est
très bons joueurs en face des petites
choses à caler alors aujourd'hui quand
tu joues une partie vraiment très
importante puisque même si pour toi le
jeu était mineure tu jouer face à
christian qui lui par contre avait un
enjeu majeur en cas de victoire face à
toi il était automatiquement ou quasi
automatiquement champion de france
puisque on voyait mal tigran gharamian
gagné contre paquereau donc il fallait
qu'ils gagnent et toi donc en
l'accrochant finalement et c'est ce qui
s'est passé tu l'obligent à jouer et
d'aider partage exact donc nous
sportivement
ouais c'était une partie pas facile de
se motiver pour ça et mais enfin c'est
très content d'être arbitre du titre et
que tu as joué à fond ce qui peut
toujours évident parce que l on peut se
demander s'il allait jouer la partie à
fond et les joueurs à fond donc je vais
pas le changer mes habitudes
cette partie d'accord alors on va
peut-être je t'aimerai parti alors tu
avais par contre je vais juste mettre
les joueurs tu avais les noirs si je me
trompe peut-être ce qui n'est pas
évident et en plus pour essayer de faire
un nul face à christian bauer qui a
quand même marqué pas mal
alors non pas deux fois ça ira pas comme
ça et donc on va peut-être se mettre de
côté noir c'est pas plus c'est parti
alors tu va me dicter les coûts alors il
m'a joué de 4,5 donc en criss angel
après passe assez compliqué ce que par
exemple sur l'année 2015 il a joué huit
coups différents 1e 4g 3b trois cas les
c3 kf3 des cats
wisekey donc pas ça dont vous avez
j'avais un peu réviser mes lignes mais
je le voyais plutôt me jouer aux quatre
et une souligne pour éviter la théorie
armida crois vraiment tu t'attendais à
ça quand même déjà alors je m'attendais
pas du tout à ce qu'il joue celle là
donc la cavalière 3 litres encaissé 6
qui laissait 6 et là il m'a jauger 3g
prend ou atypiques déjà watts hippique
de christian cointe lui christian
strache est bon mais c'est très bien
joué ça m'a fait réfléchir parce qu'en
fait je connais quand les blancs jouent
avec les lecavalier en c3 ouais dalle
rapidement dans ses caisses et 3 4 6 g
trois des cinq points quel point tu
connaissais plus facilement mais là est
le 43 j'étais un peu troublés où j'aurai
essayé de de réfléchir bon finalement je
veux le coup logique avec six attaquants
4 détroit et il joue avec des 3 donc ils
retardent le développement de ce
quartier peut-être qu'il voudra sortie
en d2 ouais c'est ça
jouer g6 alors là c'est bon bon je suis
un joueur de champ de kétou donc femme
qui est ton confiant qu'ils trouvent
j'ai deux foulées c'est petit rock des
cinq juges dont il ya tout de suite des
cinq puisque s'ils jouent petit rôle
d'abord il peut jouer qu'à elle et ses
trois amis j'ai sur des cinq après
peut-être des thèmes avec lecavalier en
l'air on joue et on prend ici le club
élite emprise ou la dame puis il peut y
avoir des présents ou 5 après des choses
comme ça je reprends des singes et
entrant cavaliers prendre et ça m'a joué
cavalier c3 et laquelle ces trois coups
surprenant parce que vous êtes bon après
c'est le thème souvent joué que les
pions doublé pour ouvrir la colonne b
when do cette colonne en échange avec
tapis en fait j'ai un peu de temps
il me faut quelques coups pour me
développer donc les blancs peuvent en
profiter pour pour jouer des 4 seulement
en partie
j'avais deux choix ou joue cavalier
français trop cavalier hausse est
peut-être cavaliers de 7,7 intéressant
celui-là de qualité il a envie d'amour
revenir ici on garde et contrôle sur os
un voile a pu jouer à chis petit rock b6
ou bessette d'apprendre ça me paraissait
mais tu as choisi de prendre j'ai pris
aux prises puis on va en prendre petit
run qui ont entouré alors tous
reviennent donc il commence à faire un
petit peu près sûr là dessus mais ça ne
gênait ouais là j'ai peut-être finir en
tête j'aurais dû jouer
6 pourquoi je suis pour empêcher foulée
c'est vrai j'ai dirigé en fait j'ai un
peu se faisait steam et fauché cinq qui
embêtait entendu parce que si je joue h
espace commun position
aucun problème d'accord c'est que toro
800 fait ça sert à rien en plus je me
cloue sur la colonne ça me pose des
problèmes oui c'est qu'on lui en tout 80
des cas et je joue à chier je peux faire
flouer 6 après il n'y a pas de cahier g5
qui est souvent un coup d'ailleurs
enfants de kétou on aime bien contrôler
c'est la case g4 ou h25 c'est souvent le
cas et mais bon on ne sous-estime aussi
souvent donc tel le tour 8 ouais je vais
te rui et là il va jouer flou gc voilà
ça permet ou gsm et ça c'est un petit
peu embêtant parce que tu veux pas
donner ton en dessous de s'inquiéter sur
toute la plage et d'acteurs cloud est
donc il ya des cats après carré les d4
qui va arriver tu veux pas jouer de 6
parce que ça bon choix n'aurait temps
fou c'est hors de question
et donc du coup tu cogites vu la dame
donc je jouais dan 17 en fait c'était
mon idée c'était de faire d'amd celle
scellée six foulées cette voie là d'un
dessert elle est pas mal plus grand
parce qu'elles continuent à comprendre
trop de la tour est en plus et protège
eu le cas à lire quittant même est un
peu emprise du fou et donc si on veut
jouer b6 ou 17 il vaut mieux éviter des
restes j'y suis assez content et là il
m'a joué tourbe est tombé le problème
c'est que l'asse je joue b6 a alors là
qu'est ce qui se passait il ya des cats
il ya vraiment un problème
c'est un vis-à-vis assez commence à
avoir des problèmes et sur flu bessède
cavaliers pros par exemple si on joue
quand même fou b 7 sur 7
c'est qu'à rallier prend et on est de
l'espagne est coincé parce que si on
prend on perd le fou bessette la peau
est attaqué en plus oui mais c'est la
crise c'est la crise donc donc là j'ai
joué le bas enfin j'étais un peu triste
mais pas de choix tourbe et tous les
huit mois la wii qui bombent est donc là
bon levitte évite la prise du fou oui
voila je veux faire baisser ce coup
d'essai et j'attends de voir ce qu'il va
faire s'il traîne trop je veux faire
baisser ce flou bessette et puis j'aime
bien passer mes pièces il a ajouté qu'à
douze coups de jouer il nous reste c'est
chacun plus qu'une demi-heure - est
différent c'est un gros de cette note
et il va quoi elle a joué des cas très
bien je le plante y fonce voilà des 4
c'est le moment alors des 4 alors alors
être ici à prendre option c'est par
exemple le 4 mai c'est leur sueur au
caire des deux mois et qu'elle ait des
deux f 5 donc effet que c'est forcé
puisque ce pion a été reprise un deux
trois fois et défendu qu'une fois donc
il peut pas pousser en 3 donc il n'y a
pas un seul groupe edf 5 f 5 est là
j'avais peur de f3 voilà simplement f3
et ça saute et le roi est un peu faible
faible la colonne bbc voilà donc c'est
déjà pas bon c'est à dire que ça va bien
c'est toi le couteau rond 8 qui est tout
banal 1
fait rock rock trop vite et ben en fait
peut-être déjà mauvaise et déjà
peut-être mais j'assure grosse pression
car est pas évident à savoir que
pourquoi l'expansion une petite
ouverture vraiment
toute tranquille et finalement quelques
coups ces jeunes s'est jamais tranquille
en fait le jeu d'échecs
ça explose toujours donc ouais donc là
des quatre mois j'ai pris n'est pas le
choix donc du coup assez mauvaise
nouvelle parce que ça des doubles des
pions bresse à des doubles ça ou la
colonne sa tresse beaucoup n'a pas trop
le choix donc simplement il a repris il
ya repris il prend pas là parce que ça
libérerait le four est ceci fait tout
reprendre 8,2 me prend 8 puis on prend
des quatre j'aime bien phu qui se
développe donc et en fait c'est pour ça
qu'il prend pas il est cela d'amender
cette mauvaise case elle bouche le style
faisant très bien je comprends et là en
fait j'ai pas de course que si je fais
rien lui va faire des cinq au prochain
coup wade et 5 suivi de lecavalier sans
vie de cavale il a et
je suis
de quoi faire lequel il n'ya pas le fou
la tour l'allemand fait des cinq le
cavaliere cherchons castro cas voilà y'a
pas de case d'accord et mais ici on se
dit aussi le pion des quatrièmes prise
mais ça marche pas sa rivale simplement
il fait le tour prend 1,8 ton franc
gagné une pièce voilà dans prend et
simplement qu'avec points d'écart et il
manque une pièce au noir puisque sur
faut prendre la dame tranquille va
prendre un gros souci quand même le
curry pas en prise donc mais si je
commence en bas le jeu j'ai pris en inde
entreprendre doit la comprendre d'un
point
maintenant ça me prend si je prends des
quatre maintenant ils me cloue
simplement qu'elle prend des quatre
d'abord il fait d'abord cavale et prend
des quatre et je prends blier on peut
pas faire d'en prendre parce qu'il y
aurait d'amis 8 suivi deux fois 6 on va
le montrer d'apprendre échec
donc on est obligé de louer fouet fuite
hélas la classique un fou il peut encore
jouer deux des six arrêts en fait je
suis juste exergue des six protège ah
oui mais alors le bleu fou peut pas
sortir parce que total aille à fouday 5
et il peut y avoir foule destin où
j'étais en train de réfléchir ne peut
pas rajouter la tour
pas fou des cinq l'as monaco dessin qui
forment on peut pas prendre avec la dame
la neuve ou des cinq sets
oui
faux qu'est ce qui peut faire en fait
dam des six mois mais là je ne songe pas
bougé qu'attend décident les bus les
blancs sont simplement ficelé quoi
peut-être que les noirs sont ficelés les
blancs peuvent simplement peut-être joué
tour b3 menace autour des 3 et on va un
des mythes et puis on ramasse tout ce
qui est sur la huitième et on voit bien
que c'est très très long on peut pas
développer sa déco bouge on perd la peur
la tour s'avère quand même extrêmement
pénible donc marche pas donc là j'ai
joué
dames 2 6 6 1 qui demande beaucoup de
réflexion parce que là il ya quand même
quelque chose qui est très embêtant cédé
mais oui des 5 le problème si on
commençait qui a donné huit échecs j'ai
pas le choix at t sont obligés de
prendre il ya une fourchette de 8 x 8
cuit et franchissent champêtre idc s'ils
jouent tijou fois çi je me bouge mon fou
ces 8es la tourbe et 8 est protégé à la
tohu et protège pas le cas les
nombreuses choses il faut d'abord jouer
le cavaly ici par un piège ou de
cavaliers
en d2 j'avais 24 en fait si je joue
cavalier décade par exemple qu'elle ait
des quatre le foulage et là je peux
faire d'un projet de bah oui dame
tranchée de savoir et cette ressource et
fourrages trois riches et on reprend
d'ailleurs fait c'est pas fini un tour
prend qu'on pouvait rallier france et 6
en trois tours baisse est donc là je
peux montrer très mal dans cette finale
mais je pense que j'ai poussé 5 qui me
permet de fermer ou c5 menace foulée 6
et menaces l'option à deux ans ferme la
tour voilà et ça attaque f2 donc là j'ai
déjà un pion de plus mais je vais
pouvoir réussir
y'a pas de problème et il peut pas
enfermer moi-même à tour en 1 8 à l'est
les solides et sont d'accord et chaud et
si commencer par
oui parce qu en fait l'idée c'est six
jours voilà donc des scènes comprendre
échec fouet fuite s'ils jouent qu'à les
quatre ans fait l'ipad avant votre sens
parce que la cie fekkai des quatre dames
prend des 4 s'il fait à me rend fou
prend 6,6 en fait là je bouge plus là
c'est la catastrophe
l'emploi et je trouvais l'autre côté
tournis cible par prendre il n'y a pas
de coût pour ses cinquièmes plus besoin
de co2 mans voilà j'étais très bas
j'étais pas facilement du drum ceci
ouais mais bon je pense que là c'était
sa santé donc là de la priorité c'est
que la g dames pranger 2 et 6 commence
dans l'autre sens avec cavaliers des
cadres tout de suite
juste avant d'aller vite un bail que je
veux d'abord que les des 40 la dame
projet de sa marche pas il ya pas de vie
y'a rien apprendre à rien si je joue
dame prend des cats
il joue demain 8,6 conviendra l'instant
échec et a priori très loin l'année
l'accord est ici voilà elle est donc là
problème elle faire la dalle full attack
si on prend on a vu la variante avec
france et 6 les mineurs l'âge était
content j'avais un coup à je sais pas si
ça marche je pense aux dames 5 et sur le
jeu cavaliers prend 1,6 et est le joli b
process is oui parce qu'aucune pièce ne
peut prendre puisque lot se fait manger
sur échec alors j'espérais qu'ils jouent
cette ligne parce que c'est un peu vite
oubliée des processus dans une
et oui oui parce que tout reprendre
d'apprendre d'en prendre pour prendre et
après on reprend la dame et c'est bon
pour le noir c'est même peut gagner ça
égalise ici les vins simplement prennent
pas mais d'accord donc tu t'en sors
quand tu arrives à le développer et on
est bon d'accord et donc finalement lors
d'un résident jouer à tempo il a joué
dame 9 au f4 pas trop le moment j'étais
un peu changé avec la finale que je me
suis dit que ça devrait aller mais en
fait très dangereuse il fait pression
sur la faiblesse mois le pion c'est
certes kiné est difficile à défendre
pas de choix d'hommes prend un tour pour
un et plus vite que je n'ai pas pu m'en
fous rires je devais me en v6 comme ça
je n'attaque pas de et des caps
ah oui alors on avait vu que ce choix du
pouvait se faire prendre voilà ce
procédé à certaines barrières web et
c'était le problème qui est un peu au
mit ces trois là on va être c3 et
maintenant si il joue faux a2a qui
dévoila l1 qui aiment les yeux pour
pleurer
et oui parce que le fou n'a pas de gaz
il est prise par le cavalier et s'il
vient aussi ça il ya des scènes non
parce que le fou contrôler sa gelée vue
on l'a vu en direct
oui le fou en fait parce que prendre le
fou c'est pas courant parce qu'il a
envie à beaucoup de cases
belle domination c'est rare de dominer
un fou comme ça et de prendre toutes les
classes du fou donc ces trois et il a
une belle position
ouais et donc la cij a tancé joue pas en
bourse et vite il a de très jolis
qu'alléger cinq autres jolies kg 5
on va regarder ça ici câbles et les cinq
attaques le fou d'allah et on menace des
si je prend 1,2 et jouent des cinq
erythrée ladoire sans fil
on s'était habillé d'atouts revient à
ses 7 et ça ramasse tout donc là c'était
chaud donc là tu t'es dit ça y est je
suis dans la boîte
wen là j'ai réfléchi jusqu'à quasiment
jusqu'au bout j'ai trouvé agisse enfin
donc ça libère une case pour le roi ça
contrôle 7 4 et 5
enfin le coup h6 que gerra de jouer à
glasgow parle d'accord et là du coup et
on contrôle bien cette case on peut en
plus déstabilisé ce fou ouais ouais
c'est non plus il ap
il a poussé 7 juin il a pris ce c7 il
ajouté le kendo d'abord prend les cases
qu'en cas de fou prendre le tour à
enghien le fou parce que ce sera bien
aussi ce dès 5h les problèmes une pièce
voli quelle idée d'où donc là j'ai joué
j'ai senti ça c'est joli parce que j'ai
5 0 un peu de ressources et puis pour
tacler se fout or là il ya un peu
instable du common man ce que sylvie en
e3 il devient très passifs ils bouchent
le tout en plus l'âge et qui prend du
prince il prend mais du coup ils se
retrouvent d'intimider que l'autre fou
c'est à dire que il a pas beaucoup de
cas dans fait notre avance sur scène
c'est pas très bon pour ses 8
ouais elle a levé foot attaquer il faut
des six il a une menace des scènes comme
tour des huit attaques fout en fait là
l'idée c'est que mon j'ai peur de
lampions mais je suis dans une
phases de défense active oncle à ce
jeu-là du jeu inverse principe qui prend
ses 6 alors s'il prend par exemple on
sait si j'en crois c'est si on prend fou
c'est dingue
il vous prend à deux on prend à deux
essais plus la même il ya plus de
problème à les jouer
je peux jouer tout romain par exemple
voulu torah ou des 5 où on décèle tout
reprend vingt sept sur v8
l'âge est un pur - les et lui j'ai une
grosse initiative et père de fou paire
de faux et a aucun problème et le roi
est faible aucun problème à faire
annuler cette position d'accord pas
facile d'être jugé donc ici simplement
il prend alors donc il faut qu'il trouve
autre chose
voilà donc là je fus c5 j'ai joué fut
prend à deux quand même sinon je
contrôle des simples qui font à la main
ça maintenant c'est bon et les retours
de bien jouer bourrin il vise à cette
mesure alors la foux aussi ce aussi
aussi je vis en d5 simplement ils
mangent tout reprend il faut prendre un
set
il prend à cet âge est un pur moment il
n'est pas de pas de compensation
facilement gestion il doit prononcer 6
mais c'est avant de concevoir ou bouger
la paire de fou
beaucoup trompant voilà tout à fait est
là en fait à ce moment là deux parties
nous c'est bon soit il prend ainsi soin
il va jouer un coup risqué parce que
quand même c'est une position pas
évident parce que j'ai un pion pas
s'éloigner le point 7 qui peut se
transformer du coup toutes les finales
peuvent être un peu supérieure pour moi
oui et la joaillerie haut cadre qu'un
frein risque et je pense voilà dix
dessins qu il veut son filtre un des six
jeux vb6 parlons d'abord b6 la borne
il faut à 3 voire 3 wii est dans le flou
à 3 il est très mal et là il est moins
bien c'est sur un bien et bloque la tour
ils bloquent la tour est forcément
demander s'il ya sacrements la glace
martin avait pas quelque chose mais j'ai
pas sept ans à plat je vais fou dessin
qui est normal qui a été quatre des six
femmes
il vient en fait un des six mais c'est
moins fort maintenant évoluer
bientôt vide à des attaques plus rien
est ce que le pion à bouger donc la
change de fond tout projet 2 reprend g2
et il faut adultes et maintenant hop ça
y est on va changer le full et donc la
finale mais thomas est équilibré ces
quatre cas les c4 reprend tout reprend
et on va voir que dans le final et après
en titre et ricky soliver en fait la has
moi j'étais assez confiant ce qu' il
peut pas bouger ses pièces sans bouger
ici bouchon cavaliers moi je vais jouer
cavalier à 5 et mettre la pression sur
la colonne à ta question s'étrangle j'ai
joué roi g7
il l'a joué
g4 bien ils empêchent les noirs de
posséder le scène par exemple qu'est-ce
que j'ai joués ici j'ai joué tour 17
il m'a joué tour à 6,17 ça protège à 7
ça peut libérer le cavalier tour à six
bons tours à 6 soit ils empêchent bcm
qui ont déjà alors là j'aurais pu
ah oui mais voilà cette idée c'est que
si je joue cavalier des vite qu'avec
attaque la tour et puis on veut jouer
pour 6,7 pour le mans oui là
des gens qui habitent en fait mais bon
on pourrait reculer je dois revenir
peut-être fournir donc là je vais tour à
6 aussi ce qu'on aime moi là et là je
pense de fait une erreur il n'y a pas de
plan je voulais tour c'est 7 à petit
caillou été mieux du coup ce que il
repart en revient de ces 6es à toi pour
ses sets
hélas oui mais il ya comme une petite
menace ce calibre en d4 mais là il a
choqué des six très bien joué menace
fourchette en 8es mithaq franche et 1,8
lacazette 5 le pion aux six faible donc
leur rejet six pôles fois cavalier de
bessens il attaque la tour des tours
détours 17 parce que des scènes menace
des 5 il faudra empêcher des cinq sinon
le cavaly sort et on paiera cette voie
là il en est ce que 30 secondes
j'ai joué h 11 h 5 face à lui trois
entrants f5 ce qu'il veut faire
quatre à cinq demandes h 3 h 3 shl
maintenant je vais y avait de l'envié
jolie peut-être cavaliers prend à cette
donne ab oui parce qu'il ya un futur
convinced pour tomber 6 les joueurs du
canadien
et oui alors si tout prend à faut le
voir ça c'est joli le clavier cloud et
en latéral ce qui passe souvent le 4
sept dessins et maintenant des 5 et ça
gagne et surtout les attaques là terrain
au niveau passait d'un cavalier
princesse doit faire
pion projet quatre intermédiaires lequel
peut encore tout changerait deux fois tu
vois là puis on prend qui on prend ce
qu'on prend on prend qui avait pris un
set
maintenant on prend du cavalier moi je
prends un g4 j'explique parce que si je
le fais pas vraiment sauf qu'à la fin
ils mangent en rep 5,5
on est d'accord ça peut être c'est alors
que là non il prend l'arrière de la
jambe et 6 bon je perds j'ai 5 mai au
moins un projet certes il n'a pas de
pions des papillons pendant qu'on est il
prend avec courant bon là on discute un
peu après la partie quoi je pense qu'il
ya de bonnes chances de nul a bien
facile facile parce que
trois pions bon c'est lui qui peut
gagner même si je mentais trois pions
ouais faut activer le cavalier déjà
peut-être cali s'est vite qu'elle est
déçue s oit bref je pensais qu'il est
peut-être le faire tu vas faire un choix
étrange c'est une fille lampions alors
on voit donc qui fait le choix me fait
toujours des choix étrange c'est à dire
que c'est là je pensais que la partie
tournait ce moment c'est la rive de
fabrique la vous payez pas ça il vous
tourner oui affirme projet f projet 4 en
france et 4 h prend et tous rêvent cet
échec et menace pions projet 3 et 6 lits
à angers 3 peut-être revanche lâche 4 et
le roi et coupe est aussi l'heureux
n'est plus en je vois pas ses protégés
il laisse prendre par jour âgés de
intéressant région pour ranger 4 fils
aymon le pion mais pour gagner du temps
voilà il voit la d5 et là c'est mon
non parce qu'il a joué oui là je
descendrai dc1 finaccord ila bêka les
saignements parce que j'ai joué cavalier
à 5 ans est logique
des couronnes tour 1 40e coup à ses
amants moment j'aurais dû beaucoup
réfléchir j'ai pas eu le temps
oui à hisser la queue c'est ricky c'est
là qu'ils se passe un truc très
compliqué je pense il faisait pas ce que
dit l'ordinateur mais j'ai l'impression
peut-être que enfin le plan des efforts
mais l'impression qu'ils avaient
peut-être mieux à faire c'est pas facile
facile je jouais qu'à laisser éclater
voilà et là il ya une belle combine sela
qui fait toi aussi ses choix il peut les
faire tourner ici la fête aurait six
mois est offerte aux rôles 4 en fait ça
s'est un peu près peut-être tout
requêtes étaient plus précis
alors oui parce que en jouant qu'avec
ses calculs et se faire taux de 4 qui
attaquent à la fois le cavalier et le
plonger 4 est en fait surtout henri iv à
la toile a atterri là des six de plus on
file à dam
pour prendre le cadre des sets pour
prendre 17 et c'est un peu différent de
ce qu'on va voir ouest gatwick est
peut-être qu'elle est maintenant on est
allé fragile de 1,4 milliard ne faut pas
le chercher pions le baiia chez plon
donc là je peux voir lecavalier
peut-être mais même pas
maintenant on perd un échec et on perdra
tour sert si on cherche à gagner le
cavalier les blancs font dames 1
et surtout reprendre cavaliers ça marche
pas et cherchent et se termine tout de
suite et donc c'est très très dangereux
donc attention attention attention ce
type y ont passé quatre taureaux 4
j'arrête de jouer
j'étais plutôt sur 10 gt pas sur a6 à
contre attaquer sur le cavalier tout
reprend ses quatre tours qu'on cavaliers
en bessin pour ces six tours échec
et là je voulais jouer le roi
trois cent 300 pour encadre de six
jouets 3 6 est simplement allée bové le
pion et puis les finales de tours sont
tout nus les chances d'accord et là on
va voir dont il a fait le joli on
caressait retour si ce rêve là je n'ai
pas trop le choix
parce que si je joue selon asharq je
peux me faire mater 5 on peut avoir un
roi en difficulté dit qu'il est le cas
et angers troyes puis le pion des aussi
devient aussi problématique
et oui parce qu'on s'éloigne du pion six
jours être c'est un cas qui est des
câbles c'est pareil accueil échec
presque mat
bref en danger si si je vous revois g7
il y avait des six que je nettoie et oui
des six aussi et à sucre joue le coup la
tour f 6 mai dangereux très dangereux et
ont bien réfléchi bon je pense qu'il a
joué quand même alors on a vu plusieurs
joueurs en dire mais pourquoi n'êtes
vous pas pourquoi ya pas pousser peut
avoir été enlevé parce que là c'est
extraordinaire regarder des six donne la
tourner
alors si si l'on refuse de prendre à
tout et on ne peut pas prendre l'option
puisque
simplement tout reprendre et la tour est
protégée de cavaliers et le site on file
à dam
alors si le roi vieilles recettes ça
marche pas je décède tout simplement
menace de faire damer c'est fini je ne
peux pas empêcher pour garder aucune
pièce qui peut l'empêcher et donc sur 10
6 maintenant le seul coût qui reste
c'est tout reprend ton prend 17 6 et 7
et de regarder la tour peut pas aller en
mai 8 pour puisque yann fior et on peut
pas aller donc l'une des six puis ciel
cavaliers et le cavalier là ne peut pas
aller chercher pions ont fait dame
métaux s'attaquent pas fait peur la 6
cela c'est extraordinaire parce que
regarder ce qui se passe on l'espère
dame maintenant puis on prend cavaliers
et dans ledit b dames contre trois
cavaliers sagan mais n'ont pas toujours
pas ce que l'on va dire forteresse
il ya une forteresse prochain coup à
être torsen qui ressemble et jouer tant
que tout est protégé tout est pourri
peut manger cats mais il pourra jamais
matté juste avec le roi la dame parce
que j'ai la tour contre le feu de cave
on va le montrer ici par zenden 17 tours
not allowed apprend et c'est fini les
noirs ne bouge plus voilà les plans
quand ils joueront avec 4 on prendra
tout simplement je rejette pour la
période
si par exemple ça moi je le roi m6 m6 et
j'avais eu mon roi de l'autorité qui s'y
passe et danser au noir et au blanc
clame 3 et 4 ça va être dans le projet
qu'un roi m6 tout simplement aider comme
en chine on prend et simplement
maintenant le roi il va rester là et
jamais le bloc passé voilà et si on
donne la dame contre calais tour il ya
deux pions contre 1 c'est nul
donc si c'est une forteresse imprenable
le cavaly protégé par le pion et à tour
par le cavalier on ne bouge pas au piège
cavaliers protège b6 en fait les trois
protège tout est protégé de 400 police
et archi dérouillée on bouge que le mois
et la dame seule contre roye enfin il
faudrait que le roi puisse aider donc
c'est joli parce que ce cas ne pas avoir
peur quoi donc
il fait pas ça du coup rabot il a vu le
bon il y avait sept et forteresses qui
l'attend et ours et 6 il a encore tenté
tous ses soins
j'ai joué cavalier au sein alors il y
avait un dernier petit piège mais tout
ne marche pas cavalier province est un
petit piège calais prend 1,7 et sur
cavaliers pro tour qui ont pour moi on
prend du plomb et savent adams à équidés
de fer d'une touriste est obligé ouais
k&b 5 quand même voilà il me laisse
encore de faire c'est cet écueil est
décimée alors point fr s'y attarder
roissy et l'entouré de 6 oui on peut
faire tour est petit et on va le voir c6
et c7 torse et ours et 6 et là ça va
choquant il va falloir mieux roi
donc ouais et donc c'est laisser la fin
là il a joué le jeu tout reprend
d'emprunt 10h de tour en tour mais on
peut dire c'est fini
balmont droit est trop actif en france
yémen dernière ligne que j'ai failli me
faire planter
alors j'ai une petite scie frissons et
trois sets il est jeune il joue faire
une quel point cette cavaliers detroit
ouais roigé 3g troisième groupe b les
pions et alors comme quoi une partie
n'est jamais fini
faire un très bien pu perdre a besoin
d'accords passés roi au sein que je
jouais à thème beaucoup est une part
active au point les pions cesser
certaines hull c'est un nul tranquille
moyens parce que tu vas prendre celui-là
à suivre le tout allié va sauf que là
puisse passer une très mauvaise nouvelle
c'est qu'elle et ses six échecs roi
prend des cinq caïds échanges
à oui ils échangent les cavaliers
cavaliers prend et on prend en france ça
tient je fais d'abord il faut qu'on
regarde roi prend non recyclables
alors ces quatre ans on va prendre on
apprend de pas se tromper de case oui
parce que les il va faire d'amis si les
fuites dame droit à 3 065 perdre tout si
donc il faut faire en c3 c3 et là les
déficiences en f4 des scènes qu'on est
bons rendements dans madame ou pas et il
faut que ça marche et en prix et donc là
il finit par molly sida il a joué de
cavale et ses huit seraient quand même
et s'approcher jusqu'au bout calais
s'est vite
oui j'ai vu c'est encore à prendre car
elle éprouve embrasser 5,3 csn
maintenant c'est fini
la ceni le cavalier qui bouge lecavalier
ont l'attaquant corps voilà facile en
bessin qui appelait le manger si
vendredi à troyes à huy droit bien sont
ils plus de quatre décennies
quand même lessive ailleurs simplement
on va chercher l'eau depuis soutient on
sacrifie sur l'a10 cette belle partie
belle partie et puis important pour la
suite puisque au moment où on parle
les joueurs
christian bauer et tigran gharamian se
prépare ouais ça fait 16 heures tigran
gharamian te dois en cours alors après
n'a pas n'a pas gagné encore non mais ne
pas gagner mais au moins il rejoint
ainsi le bruit le titre donc ouais ouais
en fait c'est mérité un cv de joueurs
qu'on comprenait huit de jeu du temps
dans tigre il avait commencé avec une
défaite mais après il est revenu petit à
petit sans jamais s'affoler
avec son style bien à lui davantage très
bien joué christian c'était plus
artistique
oui avec des parties c'est incroyable
assez incroyable des retournements
histoires contes andrei incroyable donc
mathieu était foutue peu près nulles et
après il perdit alors oui oui des fêtes
qui devait faire mal mais après la
commune est revenue ensuite tout de
suite après d'ailleurs il a battu jim
aussi il a fait un bon championnat un
peu le magicien houdini on la voit ouais
c'est typique de lune joue tous à fond
forcément ya des hauts des bas et quand
ça marche
alors pour expression dernière question
de nous quitter été sélectionné dans
l'équipe de france le prochain rendez
vous l'équipe de france donc c'est à
reykjavik qui en neuf ans donc là la
sélection a été faite championnats
d'europe par équipes d'europe par
équipes et des nappes des nations vont
donc bon l'équipe on la connaît déjà l
équipe et les ténè début juillet pour
maxime maxime
laurent etienne c'est des trois
indéboulonnables nov
après c'était compliqué c'est beaucoup
de monde il ya il ya par andré luiz
ladislav quelques chefs mais ensuite ça
tigran romane
christian qui a perdu pas mal de points
cette année et andré à peu près le noyau
de l'équipe que les dernières jetez y
rester cinq jours là et c'était bon
cette année c'est assez ouvert sauf que
andrei vladislav a gagné 50 points en
deux mois fait une énorme année donc il
était 4e français avec une petite marge
d'avancé sur tous les autres encore
sachant qu'il a très bien joué les deux
de la compétition on a été vice champion
d'europe et aux olympiades or il est
passé oui parce qu'il est bien venu
passer la vie d'un équipe de france un
moment donné je crois il avait fait
ouais mais là il était et est revenu à 2
ans très motivés on a frôlé titre et la
dernière il est également très motivé
donc j'ai pris vlad et ensuite il y
avait la question du cinquième sachant
que romain et et 2700 marne
oui là c'était un peu compliqué
meilleurs au mois a été notre meilleur
joueur des deux dernières années
voilà après c'est compliqué parce que
évidemment tigran tigre had était comme
un sérieux concurrent cette hésitation
sont concernés ce jour et c'était dur de
faire le choix de paul prendre que je
pense qu'il a largement sa pression
bouger on a opté pour la continuité pour
cette année verra ce que ça donne
ensuite bon ben si ça marche pas tarek
beaucoup de joueurs possibles à prendre
et voilà donc c'est ouvert bien sûr
l'équipe de france merci beaucoup c'est
bastien d'avoir participé à cette
émission merci de nous avoir suivis et
donc je vous donne rendez-vous pour une
prochaine émission d'i wanna be tv un
tome 3